[Música]
cuando yo estaba estudiando
nanotecnología en una clase de química
el profesor empezó a hablar sobre la
absorción dentro de mi cabeza yo pensaba
porque dice absorción si es absorción
el profesor continúa con ciclo con su
clase mencionando que con la absorción
se podrían resolver problemas
ambientales
embargo yo seguía pensando que estaba
equivocado y estaba esperando el momento
indicado para levantar la mano y decirle
doctor no es absorción sino a absorción
y obviamente quedar como el héroe del
salón la niña que había corregido al
profesor
pero qué bueno que no lo hice y
seguramente muchos de ustedes también
están pensando lo mismo que yo hace
algunos años y por eso he dado a la
tarea de hacer un diagrama puntual y
específico de lo que estos dos conceptos
significan yo creo que todos aquí
conocemos a homero simpson y sabemos que
le encanta y le apasiona comer y ahí
está la diferencia en ver en ese homero
simpson que se está comiendo una rica y
deliciosa dona de chocolate a eso se le
conoce como absorción que significa que
se introduce dentro de un material o de
un cuerpo pero a cuantos de ustedes
cuando eran pequeños no nos aventaron al
pastel de su cumpleaños
bueno pues déjenme decirles que su cara
y el pastel estaban viviendo un proceso
de absorción
y la absorción se refiere a que se queda
en la superficie de un material o de un
cuerpo y no esto no es una clase de
química bienvenidos al mundo de la
absorción lo que yo no sabía es que años
después este concepto de absorción me
llevaría a desarrollar una posible
solución para las problemáticas del agua
la absorción me llevó a desarrollar los
nano absorbentes magnéticos
constantemente cuando encendemos la
televisión prendemos nuestra computadora
o leemos los periódicos vemos y
observamos que existe la necesidad de
actuar por nuestro medio ambiente
incluso muchas veces nos quejamos que
hace calor cuando vamos manejando y
pasamos al lado de un río contaminado
incluso subimos las ventanas del carro
porque huele feo yo creo que todos en
esta sala hemos visto la contaminación
del agua el agua es fundamental en
nuestra vida bueno siempre el auto ni la
utilizamos aunque algunos no se bañan el
día de hoy o no se hayan bañado el día
de hoy
sin embargo el agua representa el 60 por
ciento de nuestro cuerpo
lo que no pensamos es que el agua está
llegando a un límite
y el agua en unos años tal vez podría
es ahí donde tenemos la necesidad de
actuar de hacer algo por nuestro medio
ambiente
y se han puesto a pensar cuando llegamos
a casa y abrimos el grifo de nuestra
casa el agua sale y está limpia pero se
han puesto a pensar qué pasaría si la
única agua que tuviera fuera está esta
agua fue tomada de una parte del río
atoyac ubicado en la ciudad de puebla se
atreverían a tomarla y les voy a contar
una historia hace algunos años se
organizó un evento en nuestro río atoyac
en donde tú ibas y adoptaba es un patito
y los fondos recaudados eran para un
proyecto en específico
estos tipos este tipo de eventos se
hacen alrededor del mundo con la
finalidad de hacer conciencia sobre la
contaminación del agua en el río
esto en lo personal me marcó mucho el
ver como la gente podía estar
conviviendo al lado de un río
contaminado como los niños querían
acercarse al río mientras su mamá le
decía no vayas al río porque está
contaminado
bueno a pesar de ese olor que ese día el
río estaba generando
ese olor muchas veces generado por las
heces que hay en el río pero se han
puesto a pensar que si huele a heces
entonces tenemos ese es en nuestra nariz
se imagina ese día todos llevábamos
heces en nuestras narices y los niños
que habían tocado el agua no me quiero
imaginar todo lo que llevaban y desde
chiquita me encantaba hacer cosas por el
medio ambiente cuando empezaba a llover
incluso sacaba mis botes para tratar de
recolectar el agua de lluvia y mi mamá
por una parte me decía anna tira esa
agua está contaminada por otra parte mi
papá quien es científico me animaba a
pensar lo que podía hacer con la ciencia
y me decía que podía encontrar una
solución para las problemáticas del agua
y yo con mis tres pasiones el correr la
ciencia inés y la necesidad de ver el
agua limpia tenía que hacer algo por el
medio ambiente en específico por el agua
así que a la mañana siguiente me
desperté con toda la energía y decidí ir
a correr al lado del río cuando llegue
lo primero que pude percibir fue mucha
basura
empecé a correr y me llegó un olor
horrible este olor es generado por más
de 50 contaminantes que existen en el
río como el arsénico el cromo el benceno
el tolueno fracciones de gasolina y
sustancias activas de azul de metileno
estas dos últimas en particular las
fracciones de gasolina y las sustancias
activas del azul de metileno han
provocado un daño en nuestra región
ya que puebla es un estado textilero y
es el estado con el mayor índice de robo
de combustible
de acuerdo al informe de riesgo
sanitario más de 2 millones de personas
que viven cerca del río
son vulnerables a esta contaminación y
de acuerdo a la secretaria del estado de
salud existen más de 8 enfermedades
asociadas al río
seguí mi camino corriendo y llegué a un
lugar cerca de las empresas textiles
donde me topé con don rafa quien me
contó que constantemente veía el río de
color azul
ese azul con el que tiñen los jeans o
los pantalones que hoy tú y yo traemos
puestos
ahí don rafa me preguntó qué podemos
hacer para combatir esta contaminación
cómo es que hemos llegado a tener el río
así
a lo único que pude responder en ese
momento fue
para resolver un problema hay que
aceptar este problema existe y este
problema es de todos pero si todos
contribuimos a resolverlo
y todos apoyamos todos saldremos
beneficiado de él porque tendremos agua
y me senté y tuve un utópico pensamiento
de lograr ver nuestro río limpio que
podía hacer anna en ese momento
para poder aportar una solución que
podía hacer yo desde mi área científica
usar mi conocimiento mis talentos mis
pasiones para poder resolverlo
así
que hoy les puedo contar dos cosas sobre
mi pasión de ver el agua limpia y la
necesidad que hoy tenemos de conservar
el agua
la primera es que aún hay esperanza pero
de 2016 a la fecha el río ha aumentado
su contaminación y actualmente está 11
veces más contaminado de lo permitido
y la segunda es que gracias a mi pasión
por la ciencia y por la necesidad de
actuar por nuestro medio ambiente y en
específico el agua
hoy traigo un proyecto llamado dando
absorbentes magnéticos para la
contaminación del agua y ahora bien
tenía dos retos encontrar cuál era la
materia que iba a utilizar para poch
para que los contaminantes se pudieran
absorber así que me fui a mi laboratorio
me puse a pensar qué materiales podían
servir para que toda esta contaminación
se pudiera pegar a estos nano
absorbentes ahí me encontré con muchos
más materiales como la zeolita las
arcillas el carbón activado entre muchos
otros más
de estos me decidió optar decidió optar
por el carbón activado ya que viene
ya que sus propiedades son ideales para
lo que yo estaba buscando en ese momento
el cabrón activado básicamente es una
esponja porosa la cual puede absorber
todos estos contaminantes en
contaminantes en su superficie con unos
poros de un diámetro de 20 nanómetros
una escala muy muy muy pequeña
ahora me estaba enfrentando a mi segundo
reto como yo a lograr quitar estas nano
esponjas del agua así que me puse a
pensar y ahí dije por qué no pegar
pequeñas fracciones de imanes alrededor
del carbón activado para que por medio
de un imán o fuerzas electromagnéticas
las puedo separar del agua así
que utilice la magnetita un mate
material de hierro el cual al ser
sometido que tiene propiedades
magnéticas al ser todo sometido por
fuerzas electromagnéticas pueden
separarse del agua
además de esto estos nano absorbentes
tienen la capacidad de ser regenerables
y reutilizable hasta cierto número de
ciclos aportando una tecnología viable
para la contaminación del agua y ahora
bien les presento los nano absorbentes
magnéticos y vamos a ver cómo actúan
en el vídeo proyectado vemos que el agua
tiene un color azul al principio y
cuando empezamos a agitar este sistema
los nano absorbentes magnéticos empiezan
a atrapar los contaminantes en su
superficie dejando
dejando el agua completamente limpia
ahora bien por fuerzas electromagnéticas
nosotros lo separamos y posterior a esto
nosotros al poner un imán y vaciar el
agua los nano absorbentes magnéticos se
quedan pegados al imán y el agua sale
completamente limpia
ahí están así queda el agua
estos son los nano absorbentes
magnéticos
yo me enamoré de estas dos problemáticas
que existen actualmente en nuestro
estado de puebla los colorantes y las
fracciones de gasolina
existe una necesidad de actuar por
nuestro medio ambiente y al día de hoy
28 de septiembre de 2019
todos estamos
reunidos aquí para poder aportar una
solución en el futuro
yo me enamoré de esta problemática y use
mis talentos use mi pasión y hoy yo te
invito a que tú también uses tu talento
uses tu pasión y te unas con nosotros a
hacer algo por el medio ambiente
yo ya encontré mi solución cuál va a ser
la de ustedes gracias
[Aplausos]